E
HERE WITH MORE ON THEIR BIG
VICTORY AGAINST THE BALLOT
HARVESTERS AT THE DNC.
BUT FIRST, WHEN YOU'RE IN THE
END OF ANOTHER LONG WEEK OF
JOE BIDEN, AS USUAL, THE
PRESIDENT IS MALFUNCTIONING IN
PUBLIC, CHECK THIS OUT.
>> President Biden: I LEFT THE
LIST FOR THE SECOND ONE DOWN
THERE, OKAY.
HOLD ON.
THANK YOU.
OKAY, NOW, SPEAKER PELOSI, MAXIE
WALLER, AND GARCIA.
[LAUGHS]
HOW ARE YOU, MAN?
SENATOR, I HOPE.
I'M KIDDING, I'M NOT.
NOW, AN EQUAL OPPORTUNITY
COMMISSION RELATED TO ETERNAL
PER PROCEDURES.
BOBBY SCOTT, SPEAKER PELOSI,
AND -- EXCUSE ME,
SUZANNE BONAMICI.
I'M SO USED TO KNOWING THINGS.
HE'S GETTING WORRIED.
>> Dan: GIVEN BY DIDN'T
STRUGGLES, WHO'S IN CHARGE OF
THE WHITE HOUSE?
IS IT RON KLAIN, THE CHIEF OF
STAFF?
IS IT SUSAN RICE?
PROBABLY NOT KAMALA HARRIS HER
AT HER AS VP HAS BEEN A DEBACLE,
A DISASTER, ACCORDING TO A NEW
POLITICAL REPORT, 22 STAFFERS
ARE NO SPEAKING OUT ABOUT THE
DYSFUNCTION INSIDE THE
VICE PRESIDENT'S OFFICE.
IT'S ONLY BEEN SIX MONTHS, SIX
MONTHS, THAT'S IT.
YOU'RE ALREADY COMPLAINING.
A BACKSTABBING, DISORGANIZATION,
TOXIC BEHAVIOR, ONE STAFFER
CALLED IT A ABUSIVE ENVIRONMENT.
OTHERS SAID IT WAS AN UNHEALTHY
WORKPLACE WHERE PEOPLE ARE
TREATED LIKE YOU CAN FILL IN THE
BLANK THERE, FOLKS.
AND IT'S NOT ROSES, BY THE WAY.
ACCORDING TO THESE
WHISTLE-BLOWERS, IT STARTS AT
THE TOP.
LESS THAN SIX MONTHS INTO THIS
ADMINISTRATION, AND IT'S ALREADY
NOT GOING WELL.
NOW, PRESIDENT TRUMP APPEARS
POISED TO POTENTIALLY MAKE SOME
MAJOR POLITICAL WEIGHTS.
>> LET ME ASK THE CROWD OF
EVERYBODY HERE, WOULD YOU LIKE
TO SEE THE PRESIDENT RUNNING IN
2022?
WITHOUT GIVING WHAT THE ANSWER
IS, HAVE YOU MADE UP YOUR MIND?
>> YES.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> I THINK YOU GOT AN IDEA.
IF YOU MOVE FORWARD, YOU KNOW
HOW DIFFICULT IT IS.
YOU SEEM READY TO REENGAGE IN
THAT BATTLE.
--
>> IT'S NOT THAT I WANT TO --
THE COUNTRY NEEDS IT.
WE HAVE TO TAKE CARE OF --
I DON'T WANT TO.
>> FIGHTING CONSTANTL